[Music]
so good morning all things small and
consequential we're gonna start with
Paul because editing the journal and you
float among all these fields so I wonder
if it you'd be a good it would be good
for you to give us sort of a cosmic
overview of this technology and these
sciences really the field comes in from
two directions one is building from the
bottom up like chemistry where we attach
atoms and molecules together and then
try and often make something functional
or something with new properties and
then also sculpting from the from the
top down much as we've done for
centuries but in this case we use
materials like silicon where we'll cut
it up in little pieces and we'll turn
some of the parts into insulators and
some into metals and some into
functional semiconductors that make a
billion devices on a chip that have
enabled our computers and phones and so
forth can you give a just a quick
description of the difference between
gold at the scale of someone's watch and
goal that the scale of an atom and why
it's are different right so the
properties change as one goes from from
atoms all the way up to the two
macroscopic objects and in fact gold
nanoparticles have been used for
centuries
I think Viki oven shows in her talks
that the kyrgyz cup from Roman times
where gold appears red in stained glass
and some of you will know rose glass so
I have some mid 19th century glasses my
wife got me as a as a birthday present
and the red color comes from gold
nanoparticles that were put in the glass
so even even long ago there were
nanoparticles they just weren't called
that at the time speaking of Vikki so
how do they get from an application like
well in glass or whenever you know a
modern application into the environment
around it well actually that depends a
lot on how it's used so if something is
you know in a piece of glass you have to
wait for the glass to break down
in that case it's a problem for many
many generations from now but if you
look at other applications sunscreens a
good one they're actually held in an
emulsion that we rub on our skin and so
they're right there and in fact they're
designed to coat the skin so they're
there in a large quantity so I think
what's what's interesting is there's so
many different uses of nanomaterials
consumers businesses in our devices in a
device case or a you know the glass you
drink case it's going to be in a
landfill somewhere where we're
eventually going to see it or maybe in
an incinerator in the case of personal
care products we could be you know
exposed to it every day so I think
that's kind of the range of different
ways that nanoparticles can find
themselves interacting with us or
interacting with other species in the
environment and what kind of work is
required to sort of clarify how they
move and we'll get to the risk question
well this is the exposure questions like
where are they well so it's an
interesting set of work so they're
really really tiny I'll add to the sort
of how big are they so I had this okay
we're in Manhattan right so if Manhattan
was a human hair a ten nanometer which
is kind of bang on the middle of nano
materials would be about the size of a
beach ball to give you a sense of what
we're dealing so we can see a hair on
our arm but we certainly can't see these
particles so part of the challenge is
let's say one of the places people have
looked for a titanium dioxide which is
in sunscreen nanoparticles is actually
in the filters of swimming pools so the
concept is if it washes off people's
skin we can go there and look for it the
other place they'll find themselves from
consumer use where they're not you know
for example bounden glass is at the end
of a wastewater treatment plant after we
wash our clothes for example and
nanomaterials may come off they get
washed down the sink they go to a
treatment plant they're not going to be
treated there they're not going to break
down and they end up in the sludge which
is often used as agricultural amendments
so that particular area is one that's of
great interest the interactions of the
materials with plants and what happens
when they get into soils so these are
not things that you're going to smell
the one thing I can say about most
nanoparticles is they don't they
you know I term as a chemist they have
no vapor pressure they're not going to
loft into the air really there are
things in in our food at least the
examples I'm giving we can talk about
aerosols
most of those applications were worried
about eventually the sinks are going to
be sediments and soils at least from a
big environmental perspective let's
touch on some aspects of this again in a
few minutes but when I'm looking at that
dryer fluff like what kinds of things
would it be unremarkable to see there
well that's a really interesting
question everybody knows their dryer
fluff right so if you could zoom in to
this dryer fluff so a lot of clothes now
are manufactured with silver
nanoparticles my grad students like to
joke about it because it's if you have
clothes that have silver nanoparticles
embedded they will be antimicrobial so
you can in principle wear your underwear
for a month they seem to like this so we
value that as a society which some of us
may then those particles are attached
but they're not they're not like
embedded in glass and they can fall off
and when they fall off they can end up
in dryer lint and you can pick it up and
that particle may end up on your hand it
may end up part of your clothing and
there's a variety of ways in which you
could expose yourself to it or you throw
it in your garbage and it ends up in the
waste dump of your local community so
the point is there's not a lot of
mechanisms for nanoparticles to be
degraded and once they're in water or
soil they tend to stay there unless
there's some other process that occurs
yeah so now we'll move to the toxicity
question we know it's flowing it around
it's in the driver fluff but some in
some is a preferred sort of shorthand
first name for your song yes oh so they
saw something else oh yeah okay you said
your students sometimes call you
something else but we won't talk about
that so it's so toxicity how do you go
about you know how do you how did you
become interested in this this question
well the whole nano I got interested you
know as a child actually you have a
something or life plant touch me not
plant then you touch it the leaves will
fall and the stem will drop that's
because there's a nano structure there
is nano celsium and the water is
squeezed from it and it is brought down
and that's where I got interested first
and of course I didn't know why and also
they some of the some of the animals
like I mean
change can change its color because of
the different nanos line of cells on the
top and the middle and the pigments get
mixed and so in nature there is always
nano at play and it has not been harmful
and only maybe the engineered
nanoparticles are harmful you know or if
they are harmful with are immune to it
we got used to it you know the Nano is
not new nano has been there for
centuries like you mentioned even before
that nana has been there so question is
they needed engineered nanoparticles how
do you mitigate the toxicity you asked
what is the opportunity I think that's
where the opportunity is making and
following there's a lot of work done
already how to mitigate there are no
toxicity and then how to use it even for
imparting and using drugs in brain black
to cross blood-brain barrier that's
where the opportunities you are out of
nano structures in brain and how can
influence it but also I'm interested not
only nano in size most of the
opportunity in my mind is nano in time
we go to millisecond femtosecond things
happen when a more even atom comes
towards each other in in less than a
femtosecond they react and we know very
little about one one novel laureate who
got Nobel Prize following that he died
silly recently I think that's where the
greatest opportunity is because things
happen so fast
then let's nano nano in science and nano
in space then not in nano space than in
time their temporal if by the way is
that part of the difference between
substance at a larger scale and a
substance at the atomic or molecular
scale that it the reactions can be
faster that the way it reacts with other
materials or whatever there's more
surface area
sure and so you can take advantage of
access to the to the atoms you're trying
to use that way that's why in catalysis
we try and disperse the material we're
using and often those are expensive and
so a more efficient way to use
to make them little somewhere the atoms
are exposed so the more the smaller
dicing something up again your more
surface area for the same volume and
more reactivity at some point it's all
surface but also the properties change
as you get smaller and you can use that
to advantage as well so I guess the atom
is the smallest most surface but you
have to hold it usually in some way so
we usually support it on something else
so where would you look for toxicity
questions you know I think we all start
to think about ourselves you know as a
consumer first but what about
occupational exposure I assume is anyone
studying the sweater factories in China
for I would assume the first place you
would want to look to see if there's a
human impact it's not in in our
households but in in a manufacturing
exactly the waste material electronic
materials material that is sent in to
China and they break up and without any
kind of protection on the mouth they
break and the toxic materials cartridges
and everything is is breathe all the
time that's where that's where some
regulations are not there regular tests
are not here either in the Indy
manufacturing and transport of material
not as much regulations there but there
a lot of people are getting affected and
nobody's following it but they have to
make a living and then the residual
material is dumped in the nearby river
you know so that's I would say the first
place you look is in a laboratory not
actually manufacturing a process right
we have experiments we can do that'll
associate classes of materials with risk
or safety and so we can design the
materials that we use in manufacturing
and those processes to keep the people
working there and all of us later safe
wait wait are you talking in the
laboratory you mean interpreting
experience terms of knowing that there's
a pathway that could produce well
ethology that's right so choosing the
materials with safety in mind in
choosing the manufacturing processes
with safety in mind so there are you
know that's a that's a big effort Viki
led one of those before she moved to
brown when she was back at Rice
University
Andre now that are you
city and a number of other tests around
the world study exactly that are there
classes and materials that we can
proceed safely to commercialization and
are there others where we need to
understand more about either the safety
issues or define the materials
themselves better to understand which
would be safe to use and which not and
really we can guide technology
development by the results of you know
what we learned that the the exciting
part of nano is it's at the scale of
function of biology and so I mentioned
that already I'm married to a
neuroscientist who likes to say well the
brains always been naina where have you
people been for millions of years and
you know that when you study the
biological interactions some are bad and
some are good and so there are
tremendous potentials for therapy
therapy's developed with those
biological interactions and part of the
fun really is going in and seeing okay
well not only are these materials safe
but they're protective in some ways so
Vicky can you talk a little bit about
the work that was just described there
you know so I think the concept of
safety by design so if we go back you
know I think I got into this concept
because I was reading in the ACS
American Chemical Society our
publication see any news had just done a
study of like in the 1990s why people
don't become chemists and it turns out
it's the least popular science
especially for parents they don't want
their kids to become chemists and one of
the reasons is the association with
pollution and I'm like well that's
terrible why is that and and you sort of
go back in history and you can see
chemists solved you know really tough
problems by developing new kinds of
chemistry but then there are always
these environmental gotchas right you
know 10 or 20 years later and so it had
been associated with that so the concept
I think that is a lot of chemistry in
chemistry safety by design is who may be
chemists if we start asking ourselves
really early when we build anything
novel whether it's a nano material or a
molecule hey I know this is going to do
something really good like for example
be a great insecticide and wipe out
malaria but on the other hand how might
I also think about ways it could be bad
and then could I get the good part of it
the functionality I want by all
so minimizing what I know could be
dangerous that means we need to know the
science well enough to know what makes
something dangerous so among all of our
nanomaterials you know which ones are
gonna be sociopaths so to speak and not
only how do we train them not to be if
you want to use that analogy and I think
that concept that a chemist as a maker
because that's what chemists do has a
responsibility to think about what might
be the consequences of a novel material
or molecule and also what might be the
benefits so we do both together and it's
an interesting sort of balancing act
because the two disciplines of
toxicology and the applications areas
are quite distinct although
fundamentally very related but I think
that's the concept so I can give an
example that's actually in our
sunscreens so the material this gets
back to the surface titanium dioxide
absorbs ultraviolet light which is what
protects our skin from radiation of the
Sun so that material is nanoscale and
the reason that's a good thing in your
sunscreen is it's not white who's old
enough here I can't see the audience but
remember where we used to put the white
on our nose that's because those
titanium dioxide particles were huge I
read good boulders and they scattered
light and they kind of felt chalky right
so you consumers love it when you have
clear nice smooth sunscreen and that's
the nanoscale but it's still absorbing
UV the problem is it's now small enough
that it can interact with your body in
ways the big boulder couldn't in a
particular the other thing about
nanoscale tea I choose is highly
reactive and under UV light can form
nasty free radicals which was the point
of putting it there in the first place
so in any case the safety by design
solution is to coat it it's like a
peanut M&M you get the titanium dioxide
in the middle but you don't want that
reactive surface so you put on the
surface and alumina aluminum oxide
coating which doesn't affect the UV
absorption but it precludes the
chemistry from happening at the surface
so that's I think and in fact many but
not all of the manufacturers of our
sunscreens have to have gone to that
route
to sort of get the benefit but then
going that extra step and some extra
cost to make it a bilayer material or to
component well I want to come back to
you a little bit on just to make sure we
have a clear picture of the landscape
which in the magazine in the journal
that you
at it when you look across which sectors
of business or most in this arena or
like how much funding is coming how much
of it is oil renewables clothing can you
give a just remind us again at the
landscape so we had a whole panel last
night on energy ranging from capture and
harvesting and conversion to storage
transmission and so forth those are
enormous areas electronics there has
really been a driver drugs to a smaller
there's a lot of research there are only
a few drugs that are in in the clinic
now there are more in trials arena where
there be a lot of potential because it
was a much smaller amount of something
you know just much smaller amount but
you can you you can put combination
drugs and timed release together part of
the problem is how do you get those
approved so there's a just working
backwards trying to make the simplest
nano delivery system he could possibly
make Marc Davis at Caltech put together
nano delivery material that only
required 61 volumes reporting together
go to trials and when people make you
know much fancier combinations given the
way things are now it's almost
unimaginable that one could take those
all the way to the clinic so that
reminds me of something I read in
preparing for this which was that just
looking at gold but there's like someone
did an analysis that showed that there's
a the the responsiveness or issues
around gold or what was it called at a
certain level like a mid-level there's a
more impact and then which would make us
rug issue make it a good drug can also
get people queasy about potential risks
and I think I think the FDA examples are
good ones because there you have a
regulatory process that's very a debt
well I won't say adopt but is set up to
handle novelty you know because it's
constantly evaluating new things
and is constantly weighing risks versus
benefits in a particular way and it has
yeah it's been incredibly hard
especially for the more exciting
nanomaterials to get through those hoops
and unless the the disease it's curing
is you know has no other people have no
other hopes so there are certain cancers
in which there's been more progress than
sort of chronic disease but I think that
it's an interesting case study because
when we looked at examples from our
Center at writes of things that were
moving into human trials it was on the
order of about 12 years from when those
first papers saying hey this could be a
possibility to when it even got into
human trials which is much slower than
you know probably about a factor to
slower than other materials
yeah regulation is really set up to work
on chemicals which can be precisely
defined in general and when we make new
material new nanomaterials they're
usually mixtures and often when we
manufacture them it's going to be easier
to make a mixture than make an
absolutely atomically precise structure
and so if you had to treat every new
nano material like a chemical we don't
have enough money and we don't have
enough animals in the world to do the
required testing and so we have to
become smarter about that and and that's
one of the places where that hierarchy
of trying to define groups of materials
that appear safe and can be tested
together hopefully can be commercialized
safely and we can do those more defined
experiments both on the material side
and the testing side as you know as
needed to to develop other so say fly
them can you talk a little bit about the
work you've done on nanoparticles and
how they behave in plants and soils and
stuff like that yeah I mean I are
fascinating I may go off a little bit of
it so plants are remarkable living
systems because now I am not a plant
biologist I was fortunate to work with
some really good ones like a lot of
scientists and what they do is they are
really good at mobilizing what they need
from the soil and they do that in
partnership with microbes that grow at
their roots and so when a nanoparticle
ends up there remember I said the reason
we're studying plants is we're pretty
sure
it's gonna be a sink for a lot of
nanomaterials coming out of wastewater
treatment so consumer applications and
others that's where they'll be
and so what plants can do is is you sort
of have this image that there's an
organism and there's a nanoparticle and
they're gonna interact and the
nanoparticle is going to kind of stay
the nanoparticle but actually the
chemistry that happens in the roots not
even in the plant but at the root system
can be very aggressive and it can
actually dissolve and break down an
apartment riyals quite quickly in a way
that you know we don't see in other
organisms and so one of the features of
a lot of the emerging nano plant studies
is that if you've got nanomaterials and
soils and they're really close to root
systems they're gonna dissolve they're
gonna become soluble and the plant is
going to try to extract elements from
that and that can be a good and bad
thing depending on the plant system the
other thing we learned is that most
plants don't take up whole nanoparticles
plants are very tight they don't they've
developed a lot of defenses against
plant viruses which by the way one of my
favorite plant viruses cowpea mosaic
virus is a 15 nanometer sphere so the
only way you can get into a plan is with
an insect punching a leaf so plants have
actually they're quite quite difficult
to get into and they're their modulation
of the plant's activity at the root
system seems to be the dominant issue
and also plants draw enormous amounts of
water from soil so my colleague was
doing work with cottonwoods and they
would just draw all the nanoparticles
this huge pressure so you could have
them everywhere in the soil but they get
pulled just because of the water flow
into the plant root system so the
exposures accumulate at the roots where
they undergo now the one really not such
a good thing that I think can happen is
some nanomaterials are antimicrobial and
the microbial community is that the in
plant root systems are crucial for doing
what they do and so when that gets
knocked out the plants get extremely
unhealthy and that's really the primary
way that you can affect agricultural
productivity but you can also see with
some other materials you can get you
know actually plants grow better we had
one experiment we did where we saw an
enhancement of our plant growth and that
was partly because of the minerals that
were getting released by the
nanoparticles their prospects are
important use of nanoparticles in
agriculture what are they
problems in agriculture is nitrogen
utilization efficiency lot of fertilizer
is put wasted and that night of the
neutralization efficiency can be
improved by using nanoparticles but that
I mean you deliver nanoparticles to the
root to deliver the nutrients and
nitrogen there so that on the top it's
not wasted and and and I think you
mentioned the enzymes that the that the
roots generate can extract things from
the nanoparticles eat the nanoparticles
are all properly designed there's a lot
of opportunities there well this is good
too i wanted to shift back into the
prospects we've talked a lot right now
already about you know some of the
questions about impacts but you know
risks and benefits these trade-offs is
always there so along with is there
anything else in agriculture that sounds
like a pretty interesting idea because
precision delivery of anything is what
you got another thing is to imitate we
have a bio solar project to imitate the
plants what the plants are doing the
leaves collect the photons and current
electrons that all difference again and
the nano structure of the leaves and how
do they how do you increase the
efficiency of conversion of photons
electrons is the problem there are very
very inefficient is very low eating
people think that in general by
controlling the the morphology the
enzymes the way they bands with each
other
I think the efficiency can can be
increased by the way another use in the
energy in the area of energy the the I
have a project called carbon dioxide
champagne dioxide is no no problem but
carbon dioxide carbon dioxide can go
into carbonate to form eight various
alcohols they all have pathways with
activation barrier if you can
selectively decrease the activation
barrier for carbon dioxide to ethanol we
all like ethanol right or a format is
better ethanol selectively decreased
that activation barrier that will be
very good and we can do that using
copper nanoparticles that are doped
white copper we don't know but though
that again shows the heterogeneity there
dope means only few atoms of whatever
you dope with in the corporatist
it
electrician barrier and carbon-dioxide
go into four mate or alcohol so that's a
good example of the beneficial use of
the heterogeneity but you have to know
that so I wanted to talk to you more
about medicine we talked about medicines
pharmaceuticals but but where else in
medicine can this play a role in
healthcare in general yeah so I mean
just didn't sunscreens a simple example
we can build in capabilities to
nanoparticles that we apply there there
are tremendous opportunities in
Diagnostics so we can you know have
sensors that we put on as the called
temporary tattoos but they're really
stickers there's one that's just being
distributed now to look at your UV
exposure I think L'Oreal is giving it
out in dozen or so countries to say
exposure fine and so these you know a
lot of people I think Vicky has one on
or some equivalent right to measure
exercise there's a lot more that we
could measure you can tell when
someone's dehydrated for athletes their
sweat sensors that can see that you know
you're the composition of ions coming
out of you are changing over time and
that can be an alert you know you need
to you need to you know stop at the next
table in the marathon des pick up more
water electrolytes err in medicine is
delivering where the cancer cells are
use the example of when you take aspirin
you had no side effect but we need her
chemotherapy he lose a hair and
everything but if you can use that that
chemical which has which can heal
listen-only where the tumor cell is then
chemotherapy will be just like aspirin
and it is possible now people like Bob
Langer at the MIT has shown that using
nanoparticles it can go there and attack
where the tumor cell is cell is and no
other cell and that will be really the
holy holy grail I think you know where
the damages I would think a little
bigger I mean it first of all I'm not
sure we we can make a heat-seeking
missile yet to Bob Langer that's it a
lot of people do that
yeah but their efficiency is pretty low
meaning if you take I know people are
alive because of his technology no I'm
not saying it's not I'm just saying we
should be you know cautious and saying
that a hundred percent of the drug goes
to the cancer cell because it's rare
that that happens it is true side
effects can be I think really you know
kind of one of the other themes at this
festival that I think is really an
interesting question is if you're gonna
make materials artificial materials and
integrate with our bodies and that's
really what we're starting to do with
these devices like actually become part
of it what does that interphase gonna
look like and what we've been doing to
date is taking large boulders you know
macroscopic materials and shoving them
into people's bodies and of course the
body is not happy with that it's got a
lot of reactions to having a macroscopic
element put inside of it so you know my
hypothesis is that actually
nanostructured materials are the ideal
thing to help us make kind of the
seamless integration between the
artificial world and the living systems
now doing that has a lot of consequences
and presents a lot of challenges but I
believe that that's what you know if you
were to go from fifty years in the
future you're gonna find the tattoos or
you know implants and the brains or you
you know our clothing the ways in which
it will interact with this will be
largely defined by materials on with
nanoscale structures and dimensions
what's furthest forward on that front
already if there's some particular niche
well there's I'm looking at policies I
think one of the sci-fi examples are
invited yeah well you know there there's
plenty of accessible space on us so for
instance there are two or three hundred
species that live in your mouth some are
protective some turn on you and give you
cavities or root cavities or if you are
going to get a periodontal implant they
are going to eat around the implant it's
going to fall out and dentists and
periodontist know that but they don't
yet have any reconnaissance for for
those species it isn't that difficult to
imagine when you're getting ready for an
implant to get a swipe and check if you
have that bug for the month preceding
and and so those kind
of things will come I think much sooner
than the 10 or 20 years I'm hoping you
know the next few months we developed
the technology and then it gets out
there very quickly there I'll give you
the other example and I'll have to tell
me how sci-fi this is but for example we
were just talking about this before we
came on the number of people now and the
opportunities in neuroscience and
neurology for the implantation directly
of electrodes into people's brains for
treating disease and the problem with
that is many many many problems but if
you could make those electrodes highly
conductive and also flexible that's
something that biological systems are
very mechanically sensitive almost all
examples I've seen would tell us that
and so if you can integrate those
electrodes and make them less foreign to
our brains than what you're going to
find is they last longer they have less
side effects and that's something that
you can do by manipulating material
structure on the nanoscale I mean that's
a far reach so I'll look at positive
take is very kind because it's something
my wife and I work on that reminds me I
just asked this out of the blue when I
did my master's thesis in journalism at
Columbia was on organ transplantation
the future of organ transplantation I
did a piece about a profile later for
Discover Magazine of an organ transplant
recovery coordinator and lately I've
been tracking literature on because as
we move to autonomous vehicles and stuff
the number of donors it's gonna be a
comma it's already a problem it's gonna
be a huge problem so is there any role
here for anti-rejection with organs yeah
yeah several the other several things in
transplant so our Hospital is sort of
built on the back of some fantastic
transplant surgeons and you know we have
a problem right now in terms of
harvesting organs that you know somewhat
in a motorcycle accident and they get
cut up and you know shipped to a bunch
of different patients and a Singapore
last year six people died from one donor
from infected organs and that's
something that happens regular is not
time for a connaissance on the you know
from the point of collection of the
donor to
implantation there and you know as you
know if you follow transplantation all
kinds of things happen with
immunosuppression we basically give an
artificial cancer to many of the
recipients that leaves them in the
hospital for you know months afterwards
under protection because of their first
compromised immune system and then the
diseases that we induce and so there are
all kinds of opportunities there and
connections being made really between
the transplant surgeons and the you know
the people in nano medicine to to try
and overcome some of those some of those
issues interesting one thing we were
talking about earlier backstage was how
your your specializations can have
potential value in a host of different
disciplines and you tend to float I
think when you can talk about floating
it's it seems that collaborative
approaches to the science and innovation
seem to be vital I would thought maybe
I'd be curious for each of you to
describe whether you've had an
experience where that's become manifest
uh yeah I mean I think if you're a nano
scientist you actually are a
collaborator the field was sort of
started and in that way in many ways so
I what my interesting observation about
collaboration is is I sort of say two
things to my students because virtually
everything I do is collaborative you
know first of all different disciplines
present different challenges for
collaboration so I've learned through
being a nano scientists that dealing
with toxicologists they have a culture
and they have a thing that they so
there's a value system that comes with
your your core discipline versus dealing
with physicists they're gonna have
completely different sets of issues so
part of working well and understanding
these disciplines is to know what are
they going to really care about and how
do you so it isn't just communication
and terminology but it's understanding
what am I going to value my core
training is as a chemist versus what
they're going to value and there's
something about I think it's shaped when
people are undergraduates this sort of
disciplinary identity and in reinforced
in graduate school so
part of the part of the golf is to share
you know what's going to be important
when you do science how many replicate
experiments are you going to have to do
and of course there's the language
figuring out you know my favorite
example in Nano is if you're a chemist
you learn how to atoms interact through
something called bond theory and if
you're a physicist you learn solid state
structure and they seem very different
but they're actually the same right and
so the field I think revealed that as
those two areas came together but it is
really I think a matter of really
appreciating that even though science is
objective disciplines have value systems
and part of effective collaboration is
kind of understand oh I'm working with a
surgeon they're gonna be really focused
on a quick tool and they're gonna be
very focused on patients anything you
know limiting experience and and I think
you scientists we sometimes don't want
to talk about you know culture within
science or the personality elements and
I don't know if I'm going that far but I
think in collaboration it's really
revealed to me how important that is and
when you get that right and you
understand them and they understand you
is when you usually are able to have a
really great working relationship and
make you know make the progress you need
now we're gonna move into this sort of
the interface with society more
generally a couple things that come to
mind one is to ask you which lessons
from history were you the most when you
think about where Nano is going to go
now whether it's looking at the put that
what happened with DDT or
more recently with GMOs where you have
this Monsanto effect where most people
who many people have a concern about
GMOs it's really their concern about
industry or about something about a
particular company and and a lot of the
interests in this arena are corporate as
well so I don't know if you each have a
sense of kind of like you're worried
about how this is going to play out
going forward I think the whole reason
we're here is we're trying to take a
thoughtful approach the field has
established some of the leading
investigators who work at that interface
of materials and safety as well as
new materials and medicine you know with
when you you do essentially the same
measurement looking for positive and
negative effects and so really what
you're doing is sorting and when you
combine those those areas you learn more
the biology and you you know you're able
to do an end run
you know maybe around the complete
characterisation in some cases and then
identify identify you know where one
needs to know more and I think the next
step for the field and commercialization
is making some choices as to which
technologies to push based on the
results and and I think you know we're
right at that crossroads now where we
have so many different possibilities in
so many different areas of application
that if we put that in as part of the
feedback loop and that's where we avoid
the missteps of other fields in the past
that regard what is important maybe as
post roses as Mistress was very good
insulation and everything it was good
for the society and then there are such
mistresses this want to make sure there
is no nano-sized around the corner in an
hour so yeah and if you ignore it and if
you don't have developed a technology to
mitigate it then there will be an
analysis and there'll be a suppose you
spend more money now to remove asbestos
and nanoparticles are would be even
harder to catch so and that is what that
we have learned from after Joseph's and
call whatever that time is new
occurrences or whatever silicosis nor
these there are good all these good
materials but they have bad effects like
you said you have to also know the side
effects and even medicines have side
effects you know so we have to swallow
that but try to control the side effects
so this case this gets back to the
safety by design paradigm can you do
better do we always have to learn by
going oh we didn't think of that yeah I
mean I think so I think my worry is sort
of twofold first of all you know even
though we're talking about nano and its
risks it's actually kind of a laboratory
experiment for the first time a
discipline is really trying to get ahead
of the curve since we know the
technology has unintended
to quences I mean I can't think of one
maybe somebody will come up with one
that is all good and everybody loved it
forever and ever but my sense is that
we're kind of trying to figure out how
it works and what am i you wonder why
would huh chocolate no I get migraines
with chocolates so my sense is that you
know society has to grapple and by
society I mean the public of which I am
one with we want benefits like we want
our fitbit's and if you sold me a Fitbit
that worked better because it actually
was part of my body I would probably buy
it but you know it's so the consumer
demand for better sunscreens that are
not white and chalky is sort of what's
driving this process and I think that's
partly an area that I wonder how
consumers are gonna going to be part of
this and saying hey I want a label or I
want this to slow down here's where I'm
willing to accept the risk here's where
I'm not willing to accept a risk and I
think that there's a there's a challenge
there that I worry about which comes
actually with labeling because I don't
think consumers know necessarily and I
think that's keeping them out of some of
these some of the ways in which they may
influence this large sort of corporate
academic sort of you know train that's
left the station so to speak on the
science front you know I'm gonna add
this as a broken record I'm gonna worry
about the field moving too fast towards
trying to do testing rather than trying
to establish the general principles by
which we can do safety by design so if
you've got a product that's got a
sunscreen you want to know how do I know
if it's toxic and that does us no good
in helping us design it more safely we
actually have to do a little bit more
fundamental science and it is
extraordinarily hard in this particular
climate didn't mean to say climate - I
was gonna try to avoid that word - try
to make that case for slower more
methodical work that is linked to that
petanque potential and I think you know
going too fast you won't be able to
develop these really fundamental
mechanistic understandings that you
really need to do effective safety by
design so I think that's my scientific
worry but son this gets back to
something you kind of mentioned in
passing talking about some sunscreens
that that buy that the net natural
all their natural solutions and you
might be a bit more beneficial but often
if you're a company a big manufacturer
or something your interest is efficiency
and production and profitability and and
and and you know consumer confidence but
it might lead you in a direction that
wouldn't necessarily be in the end the
the best choice for where you're talking
about
I went all the money flowing into the
field how much of it is related to the
sustainability questions or as opposed
to the boy can we manufacture sweaters
more efficiently now or whatever a while
ago at least four years ago the
consumers we are wanting more green
products but then the economy became bad
they got away from that but there was a
survey done which showed that the
consumers wanted green products there
was a US News I remember the cover says
go green or God of Business
there was a there was a cover page and
that was consumer driven and that's
because there are Association there's an
association in UK which showed that
every sample of breastmilk analyzed
Shore cancer converts every not not 99.9
every sample of the breast milk analyzed
some carcinogenic compound so when that
came out along with some other company
which which marks red guru green then
consumers are driven that way until the
economy suffered yeah let's go back to
cosmetics for a second sure does for me
those are a great thermometer of public
perception so right tell you secret I
like going to cosmetics counters and
when you go to them in the US nanos used
for promotion of cosmetics and if you go
to cosmetics counters in most Asian
countries you charge more for things
that are nano and if you go in Europe
you don't mention nano and that's
something that that we as a community
are trying to address so exactly the
Association you made that people don't
think of nano is GMO but have an
understanding of what it is we're doing
that isn't supplied by a science fiction
and it is really a race right now for
that public perception a place well let
me talk about another field for a second
so plastic microspheres are being taken
out of cosmetics because of the
environmental consequences and the
replacement for them may well be some
natural nano products there there's some
that are being tested now by a number of
different companies that will be
biodegradable and safe ways to deliver
the the cosmetics that don't have any of
the consequences that the plastics do I
think you'll see those you'll see those
opportunities biodegradability is great
but it is controlled biodegradability
the others you don't know we don't want
to make it and biodegrade tomorrow it's
going to be in their shelf for six
months one year so what you want to do
biodegrade in maybe in one year or
something when it get to the river water
and so on so the control
biodegradability is the key key key
opportunity I think so if this brings up
something else which is the record
you mentioned Europe the difference in
Europe and perception and here and in
Asia in dealing with all these issues
GMOs nuclear power this I assume CRISPR
you know genetic technology coming
forward you know I think we would like
to think there's one sense of what the
precautionary principle is but I've yet
to find it that everyone in this room
might have a somewhat more common sense
of precaution when they look at
technology and innovation because there
are sort of a select audience but but
that you look at the global landscape
and it's all over the place so there
will be opposition there will be people
who will and organizations that will
come at you in a hard way I've seen in
the literature already I think you see
headlines when a piece that was in our
background briefing from Business
Insider from last year talks about over
the pad this is the Patagonia fleece
finding how much of this fleece is out
in nature and it says a shocking amount
of these fibers more than 64,000 pounds
into oceans and streams every day but
sixty four thousand pounds over a lot of
oceans is and then you get to this
question of it
actual measurement of impact is
different than measuring presence of
something so I but it's gonna be it's
gonna be a fight there will be it's less
likely to have opposition from the east
we I think the Eastern culture cares for
the human beings and plants and bees and
so on and so forth I think they are not
saying Western doesn't what instance
seems to care two fighters for three
thousand years they have been studying
conscience and soul and things like that
I think they'll be less opposition from
that part of the world wanting to care
for the planet you know leave the planet
better than I found it so but there may
be opposition from some countries but as
a whole maybe less but as the
manufacturer must be hurt because Europe
even on standard chemical they require
testing on chemicals that we let right
into the market how right I think some
of the most compelling social science
I've seen on why cultural differences
are there and this is kind of a
catch-all word but it sort of
intuitively made sense to me it has to
do trust so how much the public trusts
in their government's ability to
regulate in Sciences you know in the
sort of academic systems ability to be
independent and how open the society is
are all factors that kind of govern
whether or not the public will accept a
risk because the reality is there's
they're kind of trusting a variety of
different stakeholders to tell them what
it is and to inform them right and I
think that very in Europe they're really
not very trusting I've been in these
kinds of panels in Europe and it's a
it's a very different kind of feel and
and that's why we're doing this yeah
right so if we can you know show not
only show how we're proceeding but also
listen to what concerns are then not
only can we address those but we can
learn something about how to you know
how to proceed and and you know what
more to do it's a it's really a
conversation even though yeah you're all
sort of blocked by bright lights right
now you will be part of the conversation
in a minute we're gonna go to questions
shortly but I would say the one thing
that I can say and it's funny when
you're signed is the only to have a
policy statement because my job is to
create
not to make policy but there is one area
that I detailed struggling that is
actually labeling on products and I've
had a lot of arguments with corporate
folks who say if we give people
information they'll just get afraid and
we don't even know how to label things
which that second point is true the
first point I don't know if I buy but I
think that that's sort of openness and
saying you know these are the
ingredients that are in this product and
let you you know the public some of some
important insight I think without that
there there remains this I can't control
the risk that I personally unassuming
that I think is always going to be in
our way particularly with consumer
products so I've been pushing for a
while on this one with not a lot of
success this is this K 1 so boxing well
this came up in a big way with GMOs and
still the problem was a lot of the
labeling initiatives that came up at the
state level where we're implicitly
punitive they were they were there they
were there to add and this is another
was the question you just sort of made
the point you made about well what's on
the label is it just X is here or is it
I'm flying this is a danger I think that
there this community because what we
have and the nature of our materials I
think we could probably if we had a
really good working you know people work
together I think we could deal with that
issue in this particular setting but I
agree I mean it's not a reason not to
label or a reason just sort of work
really hard to make sure the labeling
you do is accurate and informative to
the people who need it or would want it
so from my perspective I don't think it
fans the flames but I'm certainly aware
there are others who think it does so I
think that's what that's one really
interesting point and I see very
different perspectives and both the
scientific and corporate community in
different parts of the world by the way
another area where this came up was with
fracking the fluids that pumped into the
ground
industry was resisting saying what was
in them and that led to this whole
suspicion factor then Wyoming state
that's face right yeah the Wyoming has
actually was one of the first states
even though it's Cheney state it was
it's an oil and coal state to move
forward with requirements for open
listing and you know it's all there for
people to explore I'd like to start to
think about the questions and answers
this is one
for Vickie do you use sunscreen if so
which kind my report had a really good
we actually it was my one of my favorite
collaborations with an NGO we worked
with consumers report on analyzing
sunscreens but this is 2010 so I never I
do I have kids right there are teenagers
now after doing that work I never use
infant sunscreens don't use anything
that says infant and I tend to go for
big brands that have lots like would
have a lot of money I can't name them
because there are legal issues but if
you come talk to me afterwards I'll give
you the other thing that it caused me to
do because I actually didn't know this
data but sunscreen washes off and in
fact to get the full effect of that you
really have to reapply it a lot so what
it actually caused me to do is when I do
go to the beach or go hiking in the
desert with my family I actually am
really into finding the lightweight
clothing and sort of covering the body
as much as I can and that actually keeps
you a little bit cooler too so my kids
you know what a novel idea you know an
umbrella too far from my teenage girl
down but I think that they are both you
know cover up a lot and and that's
actually net safer because the reality
is if unless you're gonna be putting
sunscreen on every 30 minutes you're
probably going to be losing the benefits
anyhow I don't use sunscreen I don't I
don't need it and there's an opportunity
there
why don't I need it what what is the
mechanism there that prevents the you
years or Sun and melanin or whatever
that's where the opportunity get into
the route biological possibilities I got
to ask you though what's why not the
infinite what was the infinite so you
remember I talked about safety by design
so we analyzed and you can read all
about this in Consumer Reports I'm not
kidding uh so the we analyze the
pigments and we tried to determine
whether they were the peanut M&M types
did they coat their pigments and did
they use zinc oxide which is cheaper and
has now been found as we identified to
be even worse than the titanium Bayer
titanium dioxide the infant sunscreens
by and large didn't coat anything
because of a variety of issues related
to
new formulations and you never want to
put a new formulation into the infants
you know they want to kind of go with
something they've been using a longer
time is how it was explained to me so
when we did the analysis of anything
geared towards babies we actually found
the materials they were making 10 years
ago so I was surprised by that finding
but it was pretty consistent across the
board and when I asked they said oh well
anything infant we we use tried and
trued with in this case was actually not
really great stuff in my opinion you
know and so in general though I think
the other thing I don't like to do we
did some really this is going to sound
strange but you can get sunscreens from
natural sources and sort of the not so
standard brands I would not recommend
that we saw a lot more variation so the
kinds of pigments you need to purchase
are more expensive and they're harder to
formulate so the suspension feels good
and lasts for a long time the big
companies know how to do that better
next question yes could you mention the
companies that are are or are likely to
benefit from nanotechnology is that an
investment oriented question large large
companies such as Monsanto and the BASF
are already using it BSF in fact one of
the one that came up with the brush that
he can use to remove dust but then they
had to back off when the Nano toxicity
question came up and the companies which
make skateboards and so on there to make
make it make the skateboard so much
better that the less friction they
benefit but I would say in the future
probably the small startup companies
like the one I mentioned it probably has
more opportunities for to make new
products and so on so so already BASF
Benz Benz cars may be at idle I
shouldn't promote any company but then
census companies they they have
scratch-resistant and also it grows very
nicely so those companies are already
using nanotechnology for better better
for better purpose many others black
companies of course many drug companies
are using for daily
of delivery of drugs here really in in
medicine it's the little companies that
are doing the exploration and they're
gonna get purchased by larger companies
the ones that have you know moved
forward or into trials you can keep an
eye on in terms of therapies they're
they're tremendous moves forward in
Diagnostics energy storage companies you
know whoever makes the more efficient
faster charging larger storage battery
it's going to going to be there for the
people who want electric cars and home
storage that's an enormous potential
market I think the question is which
companies won't but um one of the
sectors that when I lived in Houston for
many years has really adopted it's
actually gotten much more R&D oriented
it's actually the oil and gas
traditional oil and gas companies and
what really woke them up was actually
the development of natural gas and
fracking technology because it really
shifted their dynamic and it was
fundamentally a technology break not a
breakthrough but a sort of coordinated
thing that happened that made it
possible and ever since about 2007 2008
they've taken a much more aggressive
stance looking at incorporation of new
materials and you know everything from
IT to nano and to everything that they
do so the efficiency particularly I
think in the natural gas areas both for
storage and extraction is something that
those companies are strongly focused on
because they now see that it can really
benefit their bottom line which they
didn't see that 10 years earlier then
yeah they were kind of stuck in their
ways and just making money pumping stuff
out of the ground for such a long time
that it was fracking that woke them up
because really up until that it was like
exploration could you identify where
there was the most oil and if you were
better at doing that than your
competitor you were more likely to make
the best bet now it's kind of the Wild
West in the very different forms of
carbon-based energy that are available
I'm not saying it's a good or bad thing
but it exists so if it's going to exist
it's good to put it more efficient and
allow them to extract cleaner fuels more
efficiently so I think that that that
sector woke up pretty recently and
continues to invest heavily primarily in
efficiency of extraction
they've always and you know maybe
there'll be a breakthrough an
exploration
based on the an attack oh yeah catalysis
refining has been there it has been
there for decades and and you know one
of the innovations I particularly like
is the idea of using nano porous
materials in part because the guy mogul
who did it has the same name as me Paul
Weiss was my colleague back and I said
too offensive that SC but ya know that's
right that dramatically increase the
efficiency of oil refining and the
energy content that we could get out of
what we took out of the ground that's a
guy and so those those advances
proceeded well much of what we call the
field of nanoscience and energy ecology
and after the oil spill the in Gulf of
Mexico they used some material it's some
said toxic remedy which made it say it's
not toxic then there was an opportunity
for companies to make again proteins bio
proteins which will coat the oil
particles in such a way that they will
stay in nano form for a long time and
why is it good because microbes have an
opportunity to eat that oil so this kind
of an open a no feelings nano feelings
of oil droplets have an opportunity
which some companies used that's where I
got into Steven Hawkings episode of
brave new world
I mean so when the oil dropped when the
oil is in smaller amounts it's easier
for the microbes there are many ways by
which they they they burn up the oil
that's one way the many ways one way is
to use the microbes to eat the oil well
for microbes to eat the oil Mike there
has been a lot of surface area of oil
droplets for that you have to have the
oil droplets in 9:04 so what do you do
is this biosurfactants will quote did
nanoparticles and and the the the film
is so robust that it stay as an emulsion
droplets for a long time and the
microbes can eat it okay another
question there was a comment made
earlier about distinction between basic
fundamental research and how you
mentioned that some of the problems that
you thought your field faced actually
required that and
and climate was sort of potentially not
sort of conducive to that so but you
could explain a little bit more about
whether you think that's specific to
your field or in butter science and why
you think that is and just sort of we
cannot comment on that front yeah it's a
it's a really hard one so I think that
since I've been it's it's a it's a
double-edged sword I would I would take
some responsibility as a scientist for
this situation so you know back in the
70s there was Sputnik and a lot of these
agencies that are funding us now got
started with this sort of I call it the
fear the fear of Russia beating us and
and then it sort of shifted to a hope
argument by investing in science and
technology we can have a better world a
better economy more jobs and that was
sort of the different ways in which we
decide to fund what we do and I think
you know in our quest to make what we do
more impactful so to link what we do in
the lab which is a fairly abstract
detailed kind of work and to make it
relevant
we're driven to make applications right
we want to show that I didn't just say
that hey I could use my nanoparticles as
an antioxidant use them in medicine
someday I'm going to show you that and
what I think that Tilted is it made it
extraordinarily difficult to put forward
much more difficult to find agencies and
and programs willing to do the solely
fundamental I would call it I hate to
use the word sort of trooper but that
the fabric of science is really the
repetition the people checking it and
that's harder to do now you have to
always focus on the application and then
you have to deliver on that application
if that's what you promised and guess
what that means you spend less time
systematically unraveling underlying
mechanisms and I think that like I said
I always I hate to blame other people I
think as a scientist I I'm sort of
guilty of it because I wanted to you
know in my career make things relevant
and I think that's shifted the field and
I think Nana has been part of that I
would also say the climate of course is
changing for that and certainly current
administration my early reads from my
network are not positive for fundamental
science you know anything that I'm going
to write
pozzolan has got to be I'm gonna either
partner with a corporation or I'm gonna
start a company or I'm gonna so I don't
have time and I don't have that ability
unless I can couch it in and kind of do
it in drips and drabs so for me I find
that more difficult I don't know if I'm
the only one so we're close to wrapping
up I want to give you an opportunity to
come up with a closing thought but my
question for you my prompt for you going
forward is as I said at the beginning we
seem to be in a race between potency and
self-awareness between what we can do
and what we choose to do and I don't
know going forward do you feel we're on
the right track to get that answered in
a way that people a hundred years from
now say oh they kind of worked it out so
I think you know as you heard one of the
advantages of the community as we bring
in people from other fields we're
naturally curious we talk across those
fields and I think that bodes well for
looking at the consequences and trying
to explore those in advance and engaging
with the broader community as well in
what the issues are how to proceed what
to develop what what information you
know we want to make sure everybody has
and so you know I I I feel really a
positive outlook for the development of
Technology you know in a safe way just
because of that that stance really of
the people in the field and where we
came from and how we interact great on
any less stuff yeah in terms of products
for the community to accept and so on
the companies have to be more
transparent I know they have their own
obligations and then then the then the
the hability will accept but in terms of
the I want to end up by saying
reinforcing the opportunity where
probably there are no toxic effects are
studying the nano time you know no
second millisecond femtosecond this is
not a tornado's one novel price you
obtained way several years ago that's
where all the novel price those kids who
are price that's we have the novel
prices Vicky yeah I think you know we're
probably doing as well as we could on
this one I mean we're asking ourselves
to look in the crystal ball and see the
future and we do that all the time
beginning
proposals we're doing this because
sunbae and I think now we're training
ourselves to think about it the other
way and I think it's like I said I think
we're doing about as well as we can the
only thing I would hope is that there
would be a really good public-private
partnership to work on the issue of
labeling labeling communication well
this has been a rich and wonderful
discussion there's lots more to be
learned going forward thank you very
much thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]